[Applause]
[Music]
everyone welcome to channel Awesome's
orbit report your source for everything
happening around the world in
entertainment and pop culture news I'm
Ayanna Wade and this is your news for
Monday November 20th first up I wanted
to talk about some things that have been
happening this week but I did get to see
an early screening of the disaster
artists will wait until the end for
anyone that doesn't want any possible
spoilers or doesn't want to hear
anything until they've seen the film so
I'll give you a warning later when to
tuna first up I wanted to talk about the
fantastic beasts first look we got to
see this week including Jude Law as
young Dumbledore which kind of weirds me
out I'm not gonna lie I wasn't expecting
to ever be attracted to any age range of
Dumbledore but here we are this is where
we live the big thing though was the
name reveal which is fantastic beasts
the crime of Grindelwald I don't like
the name I don't get why it's still
fantastic beasts in the title we know
that it's a sequel so it I don't know we
get it why keep fantastic these are we
gonna still see more beasts are really
going to focus on Grindelwald it seems
like a lot so I don't like it let me
know in the comments down below if you
disagreed don't worry I already know
that you did some other things we saw
this week were a few trailers first up
was the incredible two teaser that
included baby Jack Jack and seeing some
of his powers we saw in a little
incredible short that Jack Jack has
powers but now mr. incredible his father
himself gets to see that he has powers
in his very first baby so we do still
have to wait until June of 2018 to see
that film haven't we waited long enough
but I'm sure we'll get more teasers and
some other trailers in the meantime
another trailer that came out this week
was for a quiet place which stars John
Krasinski and his wife Emily Blunt and I
love that they're doing movie go
that's awesome and the movie itself
looks pretty exciting it's not giving
too much away it looks very scary almost
M night Shyamalan s with like some
monsters that you're not sure what's
happening but it centers around a family
who has to be completely silent
otherwise something can view them and
punch them what is it don't know it we
see some giant claw marks on the wall
could be a giant monster could be
Cloverfield type of situation we don't
know so I'm definitely very intrigued by
this trailer to see more that film will
come out in April and I'm sure hopefully
we'll see more in the meantime maybe not
too much I kind of like the anticipation
another trailer we saw this week was for
Deadpool 2 with a little homage to Bob
Roth for any of you who have ever spent
hours of watching Bob Ross on Netflix
you all know first off his look he has
the classic Bob Ross hair silhouette
over his Deadpool costume and draws some
happy little trees and other things on
his pre wetted canvas I even love the
little names that they gave of each of
the paints that scroll on the bottom of
the screen and that classic wrapping of
the brush along side to dry it off and
get rid of the previous paint color and
we also got to see some footage from the
film as well but I would definitely just
watch Deadpool to Bob Ross all day yeah
but it was entertaining another trailer
we got this week was for rampage ha ha
why is this movie happening guys
whatever I love the game grew up with
the game in fact replay in Andersonville
is my local bar that has arcade games
that is my go-to game every time love
that game and hey the movie is set in
Chicago so ok I get it you're directly
appealing to me and things I like fine
I'll see it but Dwayne the rock Johnson
and in albino gorilla George has made
friends because humans don't really get
way he gets animals
and let's just get him and all of a
sudden there's some interaction with
meteorites something that falls and it's
like it releases a green gas and then
all of a sudden the grill is angry and
growing big and then he's gonna go on a
rampage out of this plane and everything
and there's a point in the trailer when
they ask if anything else has happened
to any other animals or if George's
doing one and they're like oh you didn't
hear about the 30-foot wolf so it looks
like we're going to get all of the
creatures we even get like a little
sneak peek of Lizzie in the dog river so
it looks like all the characters are
there I'm they're not going the video
game route it looks like they're really
trying to make it scientific and
realistic so okay as long as I get some
a shot of George punching through some
windows and eating some people and then
puking out something good that he wasn't
supposed to eat or electrocute it or
something I would like a couple of those
in there and I'll be happy what I won't
be getting it looks like is if one of
them dies they won't schrick down into a
tiny human and then wander off screen
off naked and exposed because there's
based on animals now and not like humans
that have had waste dumped on them but
yes so that movie comes out in April of
2018 and I can definitely wait until
then okay I'm going to go into my review
of the disaster artist so for any of you
that would like to leave now is your
time welcome back all the people who
clicked on one of the links that was
linked below that said you can skip to
this point of the video not have to
watch me talk before hi hi your club
just sneaky here we go
okay I loved it I thought it was a
really great movie for anyone who has
read the book or listened to the
audiobook I prefer the book version over
this it seems like the movie was a
little shorter and they probably could
have packed some more stuff in but one
of the things I definitely liked about
it was it was more streamlined and
linear one of the issues I had with
reading the book was it kind of jumped
through time and sometime I was confused
if the movie was happening yet the room
was happening yet or anything else so it
was kind of hard to follow Greg and
Tommy's friendship sometimes whereas in
the movie
it's very linear and they definitely
make you feel what they want you to feel
in those moments when you're mad at
Tommy they fun to live on your stuff
together when they want you to feel bad
for Tommy they kind of show how he's
just trying to help people when they
want you to feel for Greg they do that
as well so they do a good job of making
you feel what they want you to feel
which felt a little manipulative II
instead of while reading the book you
kind of get a really good like you get
to pick and choose what you feel at each
time and it jumps around and sometimes
you love and hate Tommy what you
definitely do in the movie as well and
the cast was phenomenal I really liked
seeing everyone playing everyone else
including Zac Efron who actually didn't
know was in this but please Cris are one
of the best roles in the film and one of
the greatest parts in the book that you
get to hear about this guy who had no
wanting this being an actor and then was
like really really method onset and for
someone who has to like shoot a gun
that's kind of scary and intimidating to
be on set with that Greg's mom in the
film is Megan Mullaly whereas in real
life Greg's mom is French so I thought
that costume was a little weird although
I loved her so she was great and
hilarious and they have some really good
back-and-forth with Tommy as well um the
best thing I would say is how accurate
they got the rooms they reenacted from
from the room from the movie and they do
some side by sides at the end and it's
really cool to watch how close they
modeled everything after each other and
I would definitely watch just an entire
reenactment of a new cast doing the room
I really would they did a really good
job and it was really funny seeing how
closely actors resembled or at least had
like that essence that you really felt
from each actor and character from the
room in the disaster artists like Nathan
playing the psychologist friend even the
Franco brothers being brothers and
playing Greg and Tommy the chemistry is
undeniable they're really great working
off of each other
and because Greg it's Estero knows Tommy
was Oh better than anyone else and still
doesn't really know him you've got that
feeling in a film we're like brothers
are really the only ones who truly know
each other at their core so it was very
smart to have the franco brothers one of
the misses for me in the disaster artist
though was baby Franco's beard what was
that it was terrible it was not a good
beard it kept really really distracting
me um yeah that was one of my more
questionable choices also you don't
really feel the weight of some of the
things that you really feel when reading
it uh like for example the number of
crews that they went through they went
through like three full sets of crew and
had a lot of walk-off actors and fired
actors on the spot you got a lot of the
chaos in the movie for example when
Tommy freaks out that his actress his
lead actress has like body acne and in
the book it's such a humiliating moment
that you kind of are just repulsed by
him and and it's unforgivable in that
moment that he's just completely doing
this in front of a whole cast and crew
on what should be a closed set anyway
and in the movie you do get that but
some of it kind of feels like not the
same wait it they do a good job but it
just it misses that final punch for me
also
Greg's dependence on Tommy was a little
different in the book versus the movie
disaster artist Greg in the book has
already been in LA for a year has had
other opportunities has had a lot of
callbacks he's not quite making it as an
actor but he definitely has had other
opportunities where as in the movie Greg
is completely dependent on Tommy and
kind of owes Tommy more because Tommy
has basically made his career for him
and written this film and Greg kind of
goes along with it whereas in the book
Greg kind of doesn't want anything with
the movie in fact they've already cast
mark in the film and end up having the
actor that they cast and Greg played
side
i side with some flimsy excuse so we
kind of miss a few of those things in
the movie and since it's so short I feel
like they could have kept a lot more but
they definitely it's clear they tried to
streamline it and try to make you feel
what they wanted you to feel but in
doing so I think they downplayed a lot
of the negative traits of Tommy that you
really get from the book if you haven't
read the book I highly recommend you do
that it's a really good book you can
also listen to it on audible is a great
audio book not sponsors but Greg Sestero
reads his part reads the whole book but
him reading as Tommy in like a Tommy
impression is priceless you definitely
should check it out it's really good I
recommend you see the movie if you
haven't read the book see the movie
first because I think you'll get more of
an appreciation for what James Franco
was able to encapsulate and you can
definitely see his love for Tommy Wiseau
and if you have a chance watch a bunch
of the interviews they do together is
really interesting as well how James
talks to Tommy in like Tommy he's like
they have a secret language though and
it's very interesting to watch but I
recommend seeing this film I want
nothing but the best for this film the
room against all odds has become this
big giant thing it should not have
worked and Tommy even self sabotages
himself at times and does terrible
things to cast and crew he's horrible to
servers which as someone who's worked as
a waitress for years drove me not
hearing the things that he would try to
pull in restaurants and you want to like
hate it you think it shouldn't work
because it's awful and it is but it's
it's become this whole thing that's so
bad that it somehow has worked and
someone who wanted just this in the
world if this was a fare in just world
it would have worked and it didn't but
then it did and so part of me wants to
live in that world where something with
so much heart and so much effort from
everyone the cast even that left tried
their hardest because that's Tucker
check around against all odds and put up
with so much to make it happen and I
just want nothing but the best for the
disaster artists I think winning some
sort of a board would just come full
circle and I want to live in a world
where that is possible
don't you anyways if you are able to see
the disaster artist I would love to hear
your thoughts leave them in the comments
down below and if you've read the book
let me know if you liked the book or the
movie better I'm definitely one of those
people that tends to like the books
better but I still would like to hear
your opinion you can find me on Facebook
at Ayanna Wade or other social media at
awesome Ayanna otherwise you can let me
know in the comments down below they
hide a Heather who couldn't be here with
us say nice things otherwise keep your
stupid comments in your pocket yeah
that's right
that's the line from the room okay in
the meantime I'll be here check it out
some new stuff for you and I'll get with
you next week with Heather back again
and in the meantime see me up
[Applause]
you